from the Washington uh this is a uh
Jorge vanilla posting he did it Elon
Musk fired the CEO CFO and censor in
Chief they say CEO parag Agarwal Chief
Financial Officer Ned Segal and Vijaya
got a head of legal policy trust and
safety were all fired according to the
people Elon Elon was listening when when
a prince must commit atrocities commit
them early
is breaking wow that's why she there we
died yeah she knew Elon okay I'm sorry
look she should have listened to Tim
Poole when she had a pool tried to set
it right she bought herself three years
well actually uh Vijaya if you're if you
are listening uh it was I think it was
what early 2019 yeah I I said you guys
can't keep doing this and I actually
said to Jack if you keep doing this
there's going to be contactors to Dorsey
what did I say well Jesus
I said there's gonna be violence and
then I joked I was like I'm building a
van I'm gonna go live down and and then
they all laughed and then what did Joe
say you know a few months a couple
months ago he was like he's like you
know I had Tim pool on my show and he
was talking about Civil War and I'm like
nah get out of here man you're crazy now
I think he might be right so you know
these people should have listened to
what I was saying when I was saying it
they didn't understand though I think
which I understood the last thing she
says is thank you for the feedback well
now IT
issues to my attention took three years
but she got fired so uh I would I would
I really would love to have yeah my
phone's lighting up haraga's left the
building wow I wanna I wanna sit down
with Joe and talk about all this stuff
and uh because Vijaya is trending Vijaya
is trending well look we did we did that
episode and a lot of people promote the
story like I only had a couple hundred
thousand subscribers I didn't have a big
YouTube channel or anything like that
and uh Joe knew who I was we talked for
a bit he ended up seeing a video where I
did a commentary on Twitter censorship I
commented on his episode with Jack
Dorsey that got that got panned
explaining some of the issues that I
thought were wrong Joe hits me up I go
out to his show after the show he says
how would you like to come on with with
Jack and their head of legal and I was
like are you nuts dude I can't do that
and he's like not come let's do it we
did it and uh I wouldn't call it perfect
there's probably a lot of things I'd
look back on and say I probably could
have brought up other issues but I think
it was extremely important they did not
expect it the things that that I brought
up notably that they're misgendering
policy of misgendering policy overtly
favors a leftist worldview they didn't
expect that they thought we have rules
they broke the rules they get banned I
came in and said that rule set only
applies to people who believe it and the
conservatives have an inverted worldview
on what misgendering is and they were
like oh
well here you go that's it so wow glad
to see it uh I really would love to talk
to Elon but come on you know we've like
I've tweeted at him several times it is
what it is you get them on the show you
get them on the show if he's the richest
guy in the world so good luck with that
I suppose or just privately trying to
reach out being like hey maybe we could
try to help you somehow well I think one
of the issues with Elon is that the
statement he I think the statement he
issued to advertisers makes sense from a
business perspective he doesn't want
them to flee thinking he's going to make
a hate speech platform he's got to
control some of the narrative I think he
gets that but he also specifically said
in that in that letter hey you know you
get to choose your experience here by
expressing your preferences you want to
see something you could see something
you don't want to see something you
don't have to see it this is a rational
adult take to take on the situation that
leaves you responsible for what you
decide you want to see on big Tech
social media instead of an all-knowing
algorithm that of course will curate
content for you and act as a form of
mass hypnosis mind control so this so
this is a step in the right direction
they also fired uh he also fired Twitter
as a general counsel Sean edgett oh yeah
goodness one of the executives was
escorted out of the building
if this is all we get thank you Elon
Musk lock him up if if tomorrow Elon
just goes uh I'm going to keep Twitter
the exact same way it's always been I'll
be like hey it was worth it for that one
day where we all got to laugh about the
firing and escorting out of these people
what happens if someone refuses to leave
right that's what happens I'm not
leaving
here's here's the cartoon you got to
make you've already got the animations
from when you did the the video with
Vijaya she's holding on to the wall
going now and they're pulling her out of
the building well next thing she needs
to be dragged before Congress and face
the wrath of Marjorie Taylor green and
we need answers about why they suspended
our great president Donald J Trump I
found the actual quote from Machiavelli
I've been messing it up but you know
paraphrasing it the actual quote is this
cruelties are well used if it is
permitted to speak well of evil that are
carried out in a single stroke done out
of necessity to protect oneself and then
are not continued but are instead
converted into the greatest possible
benefit for the subjects
the greatest convert so that's my
message to Elon convert this convert
this moment
into the greatest possible benefit for
this object so who should we have uh I
you know in terms of replacing Vijaya
I'd say I don't know
um Donald Trump James Lindsay
you know James Lindsay are you working
right now what are you working on he
should only appoint people that are
currently banned on Twitter my Twitter
trust and safety team my no Milo's
Milo's busy with interning for Marjorie
Taylor green who is the um uh important
work Ron Paul friggin Ron Ron Paul
Martin was it Martha um
the the liberal who is the who was um
Julian Assange Edward Snowden make it
make them official advisors make them
officially join us company Julian
Assange get him in there snow didn't get
him in there what was what was her exact
role
the head of trust and safety do I just
get rid of that department
because I don't think her apartment
actually cared about trust safety sure
sure but look some there there are
people who post criminal and you know
images right of child abuse is the
easiest example you do need someone to
be like hey we are actively making sure
this stuff is not it's not easy I mean
of all nights to not have Ian on we kind
of could use his perspective because he
did this stuff with Minds you know he
compounded it he did a lot of the stuff
Megan Murphy excuse me Megan Murphy
right right right yeah so uh anyway
you know uh there's a lot of hard work
that goes into action look wait wait
censorship is good all right hold on
censorship is good censorship is is a
neutral term what we're saying what what
we don't like is political and biased
censorship what we do like is when they
censor images of child abuse absolutely
and then forward that to the police and
have those people arrested or if you're
like hey I know how to break into the
bank here's the code here's the exactly
security route Etc that is censorship
and so for someone to be sitting back
there being like here's Tim Poole's
social security number exactly get it
out of there doxing I'm not I disagree
with even though doxing's First
Amendment you're allowed to do it sure I
think we all agree they did it delivers
a tick tock right so address name
whatever like revenge porn right I'm
against Revenge one so you need someone
sitting there reviewing content to pull
that stuff the problem is they decided
certain political Concepts were also
objectionable and that's where we said
hey hey hey hey hey that's bad that
journalism not just political Concepts
but actual journalism and whether you
were on the left wing or right wing a
lot of people got hit because they dared
to question The Establishment the agenda
and the official narratives that are
being shoved down our throats and a lot
of people a lot of people just think
it's it's right-wing institutions no a
lot of left-wing institutions uh
anti-war.com free thought project uh
antimedia.com so many other individuals
got hit and they were and a lot of
people have forgotten about them but
these individuals also deserve to have
their accounts back deserve uh carry out
weather also another individual banned
on Twitter for some reason she's also
another fellow Anarchist again that was
just hit and dinged for what expressing
critical thinking of what they were
trying to get us all to conform to look
that that's why I'm calling for a
general amnesty just to bring back the
crass and steam Brothers
called for Trump to be reinstated
breaking news he says somebody
Luke mentioned this the other day but
these journalists right now are going
yes yes yes yes
right now there's like alarms going off
at newsrooms and they're like the
Coliseum is reopening Trump may be
coming back yeah we got to get a team
together for this I'm gonna call the
advertisers let them know our views are
going through the roof let's get it
you've seen that that video they made of
like of like Elon in the uh in the
control room and then
Twitter so this could potentially happen
tomorrow right well the second Trump
comes back onto Twitter there's a
certain Republican politician who thinks
he's a contender for 2024 who's going to
lose like all of the the Limelight
Mike Pence a lot of these Republicans
have benefited like that think that they
have a chance at 24 us but have
benefited from Trump not being on the
Town Square so and he's about to
re-enter the arena is he because he says
he's not going to do it well Donald
Trump said specifically I don't care
um
but he publicly said I don't care I
don't want to be on Elon musk's platform
I want to be on Truth social that's what
he said let's just say that it has to be
on Twitter let's just say I know you
does but he says he's not going to and
he has a big ego and his ego usually
decides a lot of the policies let's be
honest there might have been a reason he
had to say that but he's going to be
back if he's coming back okay okay so
right now uh a fatter version of me is
is being tweeted about by Benny Johnson
is a clip so I I want to play it because
I don't even know what I'm saying in
this with a list of private phone
numbers addresses yet Kathy Griffin
she's fine the guy who threatened the
lives of these kids in Covington and
said lock them in the school and burn it
down you did nothing I mean he got
suspended I take his tweets down was he
banned for threatening the lives of kids
absolutely not so again we have and I'm
I'm happy to talk about all these
details we have our policies that are
meant to protect people and they're
meant to enable free expression as long
as you're not trying to silence somebody
else now we take a variety of different
enforcement mechanisms around that
sometimes you get warned sometimes your
Tweet is forced to be deleted it's a
very rare occasion where we will
outright suspend someone without any
sort of warning
that's them laughing to understand
what's happening what did you guys do
with it but Tim those accounts were
actioned they may not have been action
the way you wanted to to but the the
tweets were forced to be deleted and the
account for sure I I can penalty for
that so I understand that what kind of a
penalty well again as I said earlier Joe
we don't uh usually automatically
suspend accounts with one violation
because we want people we want people to
understand what they did wrong and give
them an opportunity not to do it again
right and it's it's a big thing to kick
someone off the platform and I take that
very very seriously so so I want to make
sure that when someone violates our
rules they understand what happened and
they're given an opportunity to you know
get back on the platform and change
their behavior and so in many of these
cases what happens is we will force
someone to acknowledge that their tweet
violated our rules forced them to delete
that tweet before they can get back on
the platform and in in many cases if
they do it again we give them a timeout
which is like seven days and we say look
you've done it again it's a temporary
suspension if you do it time out you're
a mom I forgot about it exactly and a
new mom too and if you do it again then
you're done right so it's kind of like
you know three strikes so it's sort of
like baseball and so in some of these
cases that Tim is referencing I have to
imagine because these tweets were
deleted they are violations of our rules
people are upset that the account came
back again and was allowed to say other
things but we did take action on those
tweets they were violations so there was
uh there was a period on Twitter
where people were saying the word
groomer and
um it means a specific thing it's a
reference to an adult of any background
of any sexuality or origin or race
trying to introduce sexualized Concepts
to children for the sake of you know
getting them into sexual circumstances
and that word still means that there was
a campaign by a bunch of leftists that
it was actually an anti-lgbtq slur
Twitter
initiated a new rule without making any
announcements retroactively enforcing
this as hate speech and then I got
locked out of my account it said simply
delete the tweet and you can come back
well I got news for you Twitter I just
did not I don't care about the platform
there's a lot of people who are like the
you know I refuse to get down I'm like
delete whatever dude like it's like
who's gonna see me having said something
three months ago that they're banning
now the tweet's gone and I routinely
erase old tweets anyway but the point is
she's lying I broke no rules I expressed
a legitimate political opinion Vijaya
you never fix the platform Jack Dorsey
and Vijaya told me after that show we
are working on a path to Redemption it
should not be a life sentence when
someone says something wrong for the
third time they never did it Jack never
did it she never did it good effing
riddance they were lying through their
teeth they never followed through with
anything that they promised and they
still began to use the platform as their
own kind of political punishment tool
for trying to hurt people for expressing
the wrong thing again Jordan Peterson
he's still locked out of Twitter to this
day right now which is absolutely crazy
I don't think he did anything wrong I I
think a lot of people didn't do anything
wrong and they were taken out of the
major town hall that everyone depends on
for speech look she got what she
deserved yeah she just got it but but
here's my I I have a question actually
because should we put these two stories
together should we connect some Dots
here because yeah so we were told right
that the Tesla Engineers were going in
to look at the code that was what this
afternoon and then here we are and it's
it's three hours behind so it's about 6
p.m San Francisco time and now just a
few hours after the Tesla Engineers were
allowed to look at Twitter's code the
entire as we would say in the Navy Head
Shed the entire leadership it looks like
the almost the entire c-suite the head
of the snake the head of the snake has
been complete completely lopped off by
Elon Musk on day one day one you're
fired that's correct but also I think he
found something that's my point I think
he found it absolutely how could he not
because obviously they were doing
something wrong obviously they were
fudging the data they were lifting the
scales they were doing something that
was absolutely wrong enough because he's
got like he's got liability now that if
he found something and he didn't get rid
of the employees as fast as possible
then the liability would be on him so
here's here's uh there's gonna be lots
of a Texas a tax exchange that ended up
getting released between former CEO
parag and I love this he says you are
free to tweet is Twitter dying or
anything else about Twitter but it's my
responsibility to tell you that it's not
helping me make Twitter better in the
current context next time we speak I'd
like you to I'd like to I'd like to you
provide you perspective on the level of
internal distraction right now and how
it's hurting our ability to do work I
hope the AMA will help people get to
know you to understand why you believe
in Twitter and to trust you and I'd like
the company to get to a place where we
are more resilient and don't get
distracted but we aren't there right now
Elon responded what did you get done
this week I'm not joining the board this
is a waste of time we'll make an offer
to take Twitter private
imagine being in this position and
someone's Rich enough to buy out your
company and you're like you listen here
young man I'm gonna tell you what for
what you can't do and it's like bro I
will buy your company and fire yourself
a letter right what letter that the open
letter that was being circulated by
Twitter oh yeah they were like don't
fire any of us we demand it for our
political beliefs they said right you
shouldn't they said you shouldn't come
down on someone for their political
belief that's incredible this is a group
of people that I think for people like
Vijaya go back to listen to the
the hubris that's in her voice three
years ago talking to you Tim and the
response that I'm I'm your mother I tell
you when you're in time out when you're
not I tell you when you've been a good
boy or when you've been a bad boy I will
correct your behavior based on my
beliefs this is someone who never in her
entire life and it's not just her but
it's it's all these employees who sign
this letter they've never had to face
actual accountability at any point in
their entire lives until about five
minutes ago and that woman that you just
talked about you know just had that
mindset she also had that mindset when
thinking about the president of the
United States When Donald Trump was
banned he was sitting in the Oval Office
and as Luke mentioned it is the most
important influential platform in the
world and that girl boss Vijaya which is
a fun name to say by the way I'm just
gonna throw that out there but she
banned the sitting president of the
United States for a lie which has been
proven to be a lie there needs to be
accountability the first thing
I would love to see or I should say I
hope Elon I just I know it won't happen
but Elon if you're listening invite Alex
Jones to a tour of Twitter HQ right now
just bring him in yes drum around and
that's it that's it let me just give a
tour and say you know here's what's
going on here's what's happening and uh
the reason I I and I mean this quite
seriously and the reason is
many of these people in San Francisco
think fake things about Alex Jones
because the media's lied to them they
have never escaped they've never been
outside of this bubble bring Alex Jones
into the bubble let him walk around
introducing the people hey nice to meet
you and he'll and that's all they'll get
and they'll be like that actually wasn't
so bad start normalizing interactions so
be it Trump trump Jr Alex Jones Milo
whoever invite them in you know say come
in be polite I want to show you around
and you can introduce these people and
we're going to try and solve these
problems the political bias that is a
huge step towards having people be like
well Alex came here yesterday and
nothing happened he just kind of walked
around and smiled and shook hands I was
scared I thought it was going to be bad
and then why would you think that all of
this goes back to the anti-bullying
campaigns all of this that this idea
that you can't stand up for yourself
that you must avoid confrontation and
then take everything to a higher
authority that you have to go to if
someone's bullying you it's don't don't
stand up for yourself don't assert
yourself have no self-confidence just
run to the teacher run to the principal
be a snitch snitch be a tattletail all
this stuff you have created this culture
that has infected the entire rest of our
society where we cannot you and you see
this by the way with you see it with
Millennials you certainly see it with
Zoomers they cannot handle direct
confrontation even if it's someone that
in their mind right is is is a bad
person like and you see it when these
videos with Alex Jones is kind of like
walking around Seattle or whatever it is
and they see him and their their faces
just you know begin contorting uh it's
it's they you've actually created this
this mental weakness and crutch in
people that never used to exist before
this is a great idea Tim
um and it's and it shouldn't just be
Alex Jones it should be everyone that
was banned for political speech yeah no
let's have a day where all the Twitter
employees now have to meet the people
that they banned on social media I have
an outing have a picnic day bring out
every single person that was punished
for their political beliefs and and have
a day where they all just meet each
other and and and then that would be
beautiful to see first of all and and
second of all you could get rid of a lot
of the stigma a lot of the tensions
between everyone and all the fear as you
mentioned and uh I think that would be
magical to see yeah I I like that idea
and Jack you're 100 spell I want the
anti you know bullying campaigns like it
sounds nice in theory but the lasting
consequences are are horrible yeah I'm
not going to tell the whole story since
we're on YouTube but let's just say that
my my four-year-old was at preschool and
I came home and his his clothes were a
little a little dirty and I said I said
Jack Jack what happened he said oh one
of the one of the kids pushed me at
school today and I said okay
I'm not going to finish the entire story
but let's just say I didn't tell him to
go and run to the teacher the next time
it happens yeah absolutely I mean that's
what my father did when I got bullied I
got pushed down he said you see that kid
you get the biggest one you punch him as
hard as you can in the face and I did
and I stood up for myself is this
statement from Trump real
congratulations to Elon Musk on his
purchase of Twitter many people are
saying that change was needed as the old
management was too concerned with the
woke agenda I have been told that my
account will be back up and running on
Monday we will see happy to be able to
engage with an african-american-owned
business
I don't know that doesn't sound like him
but but it's important to note here that
in May of this year Elon Musk
specifically said that when he would buy
Twitter he would allow the former
president of the United States Donald
Trump to return with his account Donald
Trump then swiftly answered when Elon
Musk said he would bring him back saying
quote specifically I am not going on
Twitter I'm going to stay on truth I
hope Elon buys Twitter because he'll
make improvements to it and he is a good
good man but I am going to be staying on
truth I will be truthing that's the
officials
real I don't think the statement the
statement that I just said right now the
one I mentioned a funny meme but look
you keep saying that yes we get it but
Trump has to be on Twitter period he can
say whatever he wants it's irrelevant he
has to be on Twitter period right of
course if you want to be a part of the
conversation yes will he that's the big
question yes he will I'm a betting man I
I bet yes
um I will make a gentleman's bet with
you good sir he will come back on the
platform this the 60 to 80 mil how many
followers did he have 80 188 88 million
it was on the last one I saw and he's
got what four or five on Truth social uh
something like that his die-hard
supporters are on Truth social his
ability to manipulate the Press is on
Twitter he said that because there's
there's the there's the a SPAC merger
involved he has to say that but I'm
telling you he has no choice but to go
back on Twitter agree and also January's
coming and Trump's two-year ban on meta
on Facebook on Instagram
that's over too baby so yeah the
two-year Timeout on Trump it's coming to
an end here yeah I think
and ready baby by the way though let's
let's and and far be it for me to you
know be the you know be the Debbie
Downer or whatever but
the regime's gonna strike back on Elon
yes they're already launching a probe
into him
they're going to go after SpaceX they're
going to go after starlink they're going
after Tesla they're going to come in and
say well you know we can't allow
remember and there was that that trial
balloon last week to say wow the cepheus
we're gonna look at your funding the
investment here so that and then they
pulled it away immediately it's oh no
that's not true that's not actually
happening that was a that was a message
that was a message to Elon and it's not
just the federal government it's also
big players like Bill Gates that were
organizing PR campaigns and
organizations and groups to pull money
from Twitter when Elon Musk would buy it
this was this was in the works uh Bill
Gates was planning to attack Twitter to
attack the advertisers to start a whole
PR campaign to try to bring Twitter down
specifically this was even admitted with
all of the money and all the influencia
at so right now Elon Musk he chopped off
the head of the snake he's the head
right now and I think there's going to
be people coming after it you know what
he should have done he should have
gotten like a a black cloak with a hood
and then put on roller roller skates or
rollerblades so that he would float
slowly into Twitter HQ looking and
pointing or fired just like and it would
be very demonic as he was that movie
where they came in with the paintball
gun oh yeah yeah it was uh no no it was
that suits that suits that show yeah
okay yeah the gel Blaster yeah that's
that's good I don't know about it what
I'm most excited about is the word with
with Twitter being bought by Elon is we
don't have to wait for any more strongly
worded letters from Lindsey Graham about
you know reigning in big Tech you know
because Elon just went out and bought it
but look that being said I and I'm just
gonna say it right this this is not you
know the get rich quick scheme this is
not the magic wand being waved and
acting like all of the fundamental
problems and issues that we've been
talking about in this program has been
discussing for the last two years they
haven't magically gone away because Elon
did this this is a stopgap measure at
best right and those issues are going to
continue until the people of this
country actually come forward put
forward serious legislation on big Tech
and I think there still is a place by
the way for the forgetter for truth
social for rumble for all these I
certainly hope that Elon uh I think
based on what we've just seen this is
definitely a step in the right direction
for integration between
um uh Twitter and Rumble but at the same
time you can't just put all your eggs in
one basket you should never do that look
as as I'm sure as Ian would say if you
were here you know you never leave all
your stash in one place
absolutely and it's important to
understand here now I think we're
finally going to get some big Tech
regulations
I'm not saying this is why we have to be
careful about big Tech oligarchs oh yeah
suddenly yeah I mean the reason the the
censorship it went crazy in the first
place is because you know a great uh
Veterans of the meme War 2016 like Jack
you know we use social media so
effectively and Luke and Luke and Luke
again and and you know a lot of people a
lot of people who got deleted you know
well that's what I'm talking about the
pows of the great meme Wars 2016 20 2015
2016 that once you let those
riveting frogs return onto Twitter and
the social media platforms writ large
and just actually allow people to speak
freely and share information right a lot
of this goes back to the Wikileaks drops
in the fall of 2016 and the fact that
people were simply discussing the words
and phrases and contents of those
Wikileaks drops whether it be the DNC
emails the podesta emails Etc Hillary
Clinton stuff that came out that was why
they started turning the screws on
everybody else and claiming that oh you
made up this and no no no everybody was
reading the words of your own emails
that was from y'all thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our our journalists employed makes
this show happen and you will get access
to exclusive members only segments of
the timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there